hello hello
huge congratulations on the movie oh
thank you
i i adored it i've said it in every
single room and i mean it
um i know it's been a little while for
you since the future but i also know
you've been
busy with many other things of
everything you've accomplished between
films did you find that any of those
other projects
experiences or just working with
different mediums came in handy for you
here as a filmmaker
yeah you know the probably the biggest
thing i did between the two movies was i
wrote a novel
um and that novel
was full of like twists and turns and
reveals and reversals and
and i remember thinking when i was
writing that you know what all this
stuff would be really good for
a movie like movies like all that stuff
and i hoped that i would still be
interested that i hadn't used up my
interest in the book and i hadn't um so
i felt like i had those muscles
kind of warm and ready to work with when
i got to this movie
so i know the story behind aldolia's
name
in the movie but just for you writing a
script and naming your characters what
inspired that choice to begin with
in real life um my friend texted me that
she had had a dream
that i had given birth to ten kittens
and she had all the names written out in
the text and one of the names was old
doglio and i remember like
being like well that's can't forget that
i can use that for something another
name that i didn't use was marijuana
okay that that
story behind the name is probably better
than anything i could have made up just
um how much backstory did you create
for this family because in watching the
movie this is a very full story here but
i did catch myself wondering what their
very first con with old olio
was like and it just seems like the
family could suit a whole series
right right i did do a lot of
working on the back story which i don't
love
i don't love doing that stuff but it
does end up helping
and there are a lot of questions you
know and some of the actors love
that stuff have questions about the
backstory some of them like richard
jenkins is like
do not tell me anything if it's not
there i don't need to know
um but yeah we you know and and
they basically could ask me anything
about the story and i'd be like oh well
yeah you know like i had written
basically like a book's worth but it was
yeah at the ready speaking of
just different approaches to backstory
what is it like for you as a director
who comes to set with a vision but is
open to change it from day to day
what happens if you you know encounter
an actor who
you know needs a little help adjusting
to something like that are there any
tools in your tool kit to really ease
them into it
i mean i don't i i think what i'm
gathering from listening to my actors
talk about me is that
yeah you you maybe think it's going to
be this like whimsical fun experience
but
working with me but actually because i'm
a writer and
because i kind of have a very clear
vision of what i want it's
um it's a matter of like fitting into
that
world and then i'm also you know
kind of adapting to them at every step i
feel like i am
um but i guess
i guess i mean for me what it was was
like coming to understand
each actor and each of those four people
works very differently and is
you know obviously a really different
person and so
being able to like keep changing in a
day you know how i directed
um how i invited them in so can you uh
can you give us an example of the four
of them like what would you say are the
the two
most extremes well on the one end
evan i i kind of felt like i didn't even
have to verbalize what i needed her to
do
as long as i could feel it in my body
and think it
i could sort of just give her like a
look and a sort of
very inarticulate mumble um and
that that wouldn't fly at all for say a
deborah winger you know like
deborah we are like wanted to sit down
and have a conversation about like
why and you know and maybe we should
email about it or meet about it or you
know like she's really
gonna do her homework um and
uh so yeah just so different and it it
doesn't matter you know there's no
it's like whatever works for them that's
why i love asking about that i love
hearing about the varied processes out
there because it'll it all brings
something differently creatively to a
movie
yeah so this might sound like a very
very silly question but what is the
movie magic behind the pink foam
you can't do it very many times first of
all like
you know there's a scene where it floods
kind of the whole
space and we could do that once
one time because there's no resetting
after that i mean
um uh and so we had to get that right
and um we did and you know there's a
whole machine behind that wall that has
been built
just to make those bubbles for this
movie
just the right size and density and
color and i mean
it's so laborious and so fun to get to
make something real like that that's
that you wrote that's almost abstract
but not quite
what happened to the machine it's off
making bubbles somewhere else
okay what else is going to be i don't
know i feel like as long as someone kept
it and put it to use
yeah very curious because
i feel like i could spot one of your
movies from a mile away and know that
it's yours
so if you had the opportunity to be a
fly on the wall of another
filmmaker set and observe the way that
they work who would you choose and why
well you know it's funny i act but i'm
not really an actor for hire and when
people ask me to be in their movies i'm
like what go go get a real actor
but there was this woman director
josephine decker
and i had seen her movies and i was
really like how the hell
does she make those and then lo and
behold she asked me if i wanted to play
a
part in her movie and i said yes
entirely
as like an espionage mission as a
director
just so i could see her methods
and it worked it was great i learned a
ton and it was so different than i would
have guessed
um so yeah josephine decker very
different process for me but
uh so beautiful i very much appreciate
that
approach to working as an actor on set
especially someone
like her i mean her work is incredible
so what in particular
is it about her that makes her stand out
from any other director you've
observed or worked with i mean her work
is so
fluid um and i wondered like how does
you know like is there a script or how
do you know i
came to realize that a lot of it has to
do with that she's really an
editor so she's never has to worry she
has
utter confidence that she can cut
anything together
which really sets her free in terms of
how she shoots and even how she
writes and creates she can she does a
lot more in the moment because it's
almost like she's writing it afterwards
i mean that's my take you know you have
to ask her
i guess i'm allowed to say i love
shirley because they're both focused
features movies now
um just to wrap up here i've i've gotten
very obsessed with finding the stories
behind special thanks
in movies and i could figure out a bunch
of yours and why they might have come to
be but the one that i'm curious about is
if beale street could talk how did uh
how'd that wind up happening
well did they thank us or did we thank
them um
they thanked you yeah they thanked us
because um
they were doing their reshoots when we
were just finishing our movie
and so they took our crew our key crew
and used them for their reshoots um so
everyone from my movie suddenly was on
that movie right afterwards and i
remember being like hi
how how's everyone doing and people
being like we're really busy we're
working for barry jenkins now and i was
like okay
why i of love hearing about like a
collaboration like that i didn't even
realize that was a thing
yeah yeah well thank you so much for
your time today and again huge
congratulations
on the movie yeah thank you so much